[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
nick thurston is author of two books
a chap book
and
three pocket books two with co-authors
he has been an associate and visiting
lecturer
at various arts academies
in the uk since 2007 and he's now
an associate professor at school of fine
art history of art and cultural studies
at the university
of leeds
to orally republish a statement from his
faculty page my practice more broadly as
a writer and editor who makes artworks
involves traditional and post-digital
forms of publishing
as well as
exhibitions and readings
his print and sculptural works
are held in
public and private collections around
europe including the
museum
leeds city art gallery and the
bibliotheque nationale de france his
book works are collected by
institutions including the vna
the tate and the moma
since 2006 he's been co-editor of the
independent artist book publishing
imprint information as material in york
with whom he was writer in residence at
the white chapel gallery in 2011
to 2012.
today we'll hear from nick about
document practices
so i wanted to give you
a glimpse at least of his work with
and published by
information as material
so first let me show you a bit of
nick thurston's
2006 book
reading the remove of literature
it is not maurice blanchard's 1955 book
la space literary and it is not the
english translation of this book
but rather it's a publication if you can
see
of thurston's marginal annotations
to that translation
originally of course
annotations that were not handwritten
that were handwritten but were not
typeset as you see here
as it says on goodreads
the premise
is interesting
it is not wholly unique but it is
intriguing and has elements of being
something that had extreme potential
but unfortunately the severe lack of
plot
the abysmal world building and the
utterly annoying characters
let it down
i'll display one more of nick's books
this is a book of poems called
of the subcontract
published in 2013.
i call it nick's book but as you can see
it's actually
uh it's actually written there we go
there's everyone it's actually written
by
time magazine's 2002 person of the year
you
uh or perhaps time magazine's 2022
person of the year the uber driver
or only a bit more literally and
specifically
workers aka
turkers
that nick thurston recruited through
amazon mechanical turk
a service that allows human beings to be
brought into an intellectual supply
chain
as easily as
computing power from cloud services
as mckenzie work writes in her forward
to the book
poetry sets a sky a flame at sunset
magically transforms a familiar
landscape into a snow white wonderland
and prints a clump of daffodils
with the glow of soft sunlight
actually
not written by mackenzie work
she had a graduate student
do the job for her
no
just kidding the graduate student was
probably too busy picking up mckenzie's
dry cleaning so the forward to the book
was actually written by a ghostwriter in
pakistan via freelancer.com
i'm particularly glad to have nick
thurston speak with us tonight about his
critical
theoretical and scholarly approaches to
document practices because they grow
from his excellent and provocative work
as
a document practitioner
a publisher and co-author as well as an
author
someone who not only stops to smell the
roses but has indeed
printed
that clump of daffodils
welcome
face to face
through a hole in space
nick thurston
thank you nick that was really kind
um i'm just going to pull up my desktop
is that coming through
great okay
and then i'll come into here um that was
really kind nick thank you and um thanks
to to heather and andrew for the
invitation to speak
and to william and his colleagues at the
open documentary lab for enabling
everything
um
well i hope i'll actually get to come
over someday but in the meantime these
kinds of events at least get a
conversation going and i'm really
grateful for that
so the the phrasing of my title today is
weird
document practices is an odd even
awkward formulation but it's one that i
started to use in 2017
to try to make sense of a long-term
project i debuted that year with my
other hat on as someone who makes
artworks
that project is dense but simple
it was about creating sociable reading
environments for audiences to pay close
attention together to the networking and
collaboration forums used by far-right
and fringe-right political parties
around europe
the project was called hate library and
it involved really simple but
time-consuming data extraction and
republishing methods
so this odd formulation document
practices was something that i deduced
as a kind of um
like an epistemological coping mechanism
or something a way to help me understand
what on earth i was doing speculatively
and aesthetically in my artistic
practice
now i'm not planning to talk about hate
library today but i've pasted a few
links into the zoom chat if anyone wants
to follow up on it
the most pertinent link is probably the
short article for the house journal of
the trans media festival in berlin
it's a short magazine type article but
it bridges between my investments in
that background project hate library
and the new project that i will talk
about today which is shaping up as a
monograph of criticism
now i wanted to start with this little
bit of background to raise two quick
points by way of a frame for what i'll
share
those points are personal and simple but
i hope they'll help you understand how
i'm coming at this new book project
first point is really methodological
i'm not a scholar in any strict sense
and i'm not sharing that as an excuse or
even as an apology
all of the work i've done that's
involved scholarship has like this new
project somehow reversed out of things
that i've stumbled on in the process of
making and writing artistically
and from being part of communities who
do the same
now typically that happens when i notice
a commonality between artistic gestures
that's somehow ill-defined or undefined
and if i can't find a historical or
theoretical genealogy that adequately
accounts for that common gesture as an
artistic impulse
then i'll start to try and think in the
gap
that's typically how i decide to what to
work on as a critic
i've always called this kind of work
para scholarly in the sense of it being
dependent upon but somehow outside of
proper scholarship
in no small part because its focus tends
to be pretty subjective and less about
the needs or lacks within any
disciplinary discourse
now today's the first time i'm going to
talk about this new project document
practices
and it's very much a para scholarly
endeavor in ways that i think are both
good and bad
now at the moment i'm not entirely sure
whether this is a book that will say
here's a bunch of exciting things and
here's one way of thinking about them
or whether it's going to do something
philosophically deeper at a metacritical
level in relation to the triangle of
issues that anchor it
now that triangle is up on screen
but i'll just voice them quickly
first
the status of the document in
documentary practice
second the social lives of textual
documents in our mediascape
and third the stakes of republishing
as art or via the contexts of art
now my new project really comes from
noticing this trio of issues bubbling up
in the field
but there being no given way to
triangulate them critically such that
it's currently hard to understand why if
at all their co-occurrence is connected
so the book that's shaping up is full of
examples
and as such the writing of this book its
propulsion is really being driven by
critical description
now my second framing point is a a kind
of invitation and a caveat i guess
i'm um i'm actually a subscriber to the
podcast series that comes from this
colloquium so i have a kind of
listener's impression of the types of
projects and methodologies normally
brought to the forum
now i don't have a data set per se
and i'm not going to talk about
behavioral tendencies or mass media
issues
but i'm also not going to bore you with
loads of art history or literary theory
i'm going to use bits of those
discourses for scaffolding but at the
heart of this project are unresolved
questions about comparative criticism
and about the media critical stakes of
republishing
so i'm going to talk you through lots of
examples starting with two precedents
for what i'm starting to call document
practices
and what i'd really value from the
discussion afterwards is some collective
problematization of the media critical
stakes these examples dig up
because if i'm honest i think that
aspect of my project is still
undercooked at the moment
so in short i'm coming to you from a
para position
with a project that's kind of in its
teens if not its infancy
and i'm looking forward to a chance to
talk with you all about some of it not
not just his threads
anyway that's the little bit of framing
i wanted to do
um
right so i'll get to business now
heather suggested about 50 minutes of
presentation so i'll speak for about
that but certainly no more than
no more than 55.
the aesthetic and political category
that lurks behind this new book project
is the one half spoken in its title
documentary
you can't think about documentary let
alone talk about it without invoking
some notion of the document
now i know that teasing the seemingly
obvious link between documentary and
documents is a trope of discussions
about documentary it's the most obvious
self-reflexive trigger
but part of what's attractive about that
trope is that it doesn't take much
teasing out to show that the meaning of
documentary is slippery if not even
ambiguous
we can talk about documentary as an
aesthetic category and have irresolvable
debates about where its value lies
we can talk about documentary as an
aesthetic genre either within a
particular art form or across art forms
and try to establish what kind of
realism it generates
and we can talk about documentary as an
historiographic method a way of
reopening the past and registering that
rupture
and maybe even advocating for an
alternative
now one commitment i've made in this
project is to stay with that
slipperiness
rather than try to bypass it or even to
try to resolve it up front theoretically
not least because innovative
documentarians keep making it more
slippery and as a practitioner and
critic i think that's a good thing
but to quickly distill what's giving the
book project some ballast as i negotiate
that slipperiness
i want to share a sequence of two
guiding questions
this pair of questions are underwriting
my approach to that triangle of issues i
mentioned which are still up there on
the screen
now we all know that documents and
documentary are not the same thing
something can be a document without
being a documentary
and a documentary needs more than just
documents in the raw
philologically we might say that because
one is the root term for the other the
genus species relation seems clear
but what exactly constitutes a document
now in an era of accelerated
mediatization
is just as slippery or grey as the
definition of documentary
particularly so in relation to textual
documents in a post-print mediascape
and i suspect that's one of the reasons
why people like me are noticing a
creative upsurge or resurgence in
aesthetic misuses of documents
in ways that don't bear all of the
hallmarks we associate with documentary
like the narrativization of evidence etc
and i'm just one of the people noticing
that in a field of practice that seems
to be settling somewhere in the
hinterlands between experimental writing
experimental publishing experimental
intermediary arts practice
and digital activism
so in this new project
the way i want to pin together the
thinness of the document
and the status of the documentary
is by surveying some practices that
creatively misuse textual documents in
ways that generate effects that go
beyond what we generally understand the
documentary to be doing or aiming for
put simply i'm interested in whether
there has emerged an aesthetic use of
documents as documents
that exceeds what we can usefully call
documentary
now instinctively i know that sounds
oxymoronic or just like a cute paradox
but i think there have been some changes
in the aesthetic intention of what
artists are trying to do with documents
in the context of this triangle of
issues
and the effects of those intentions are
motivating something at least slightly
different
this is a change of intention that might
be epitomized in the extreme by
something like file sharing or maybe
better yet shadow libraries
it's a change in intention and gesture
that's creating new aesthetic effects
effects that have stakes or consequences
that are more than just cute
so the first of those guiding questions
i promise would be an art critical one
are these practices that i'm gathering
under the umbrella document practices
somehow exceeding what we can usefully
recognize as documentary
or are they just a limit case for one
more way that documentary practice is
changing in response to the world
that's the little bit of art discourse
scaffolding that i've warned you about
but the second question
the second knock-on guiding question
opens beyond our critical discourse
and it's simply the question of how and
why
whether document practices are nudging
one horizon of the documentary
or they constitute a break from the
documentary
how and why do these projects do what
they do
and it's with that second question that
my commitment to critical description as
an analytical method is pinned
now in its drafting this book i'm
working on this teenager
is organizing an answer to that pair of
guiding questions through six chapters
each chapter has a thematic anchor
the first looks at the legacies of
montage in experimental print and
post-print literary publishing
the second chapter looks at testimony in
textual records and the aesthetic use of
that testimony
the third chapter centers on the big
question about facticity about the truth
claims we mobilize published documents
to underwrite
the fourth chapter focuses on
declarations or the idea of telling
evidence and how that idea is being
inflected by the growth and size and
availability of data sets of documents
the fifth chapter addresses shifting
notions of publicness or how sharing and
republishing documents can be a mode of
explicitly ideological counteraction
and the sixth final chapter looks at
bottom-up structures for organizing
public access to documents platforms
effectively
from shadow libraries to print-on-demand
models
now the straightforward editorial
principle for my book is that the theme
for each chapter then anchors a set of
examples
the slightly less straightforward
application of that principle is that
each theme currently anchors a lot of
examples probably far too many
which is just really a consequence of my
enthusiasm but also of the paris
scholarly method i mentioned
the fact that i'm reversing into
critical writing from practice or from
the field if you like
and we all know that things are kind of
exciting but messy in the field
now i've known williams work on
participatory culture for a while but i
first came across the work of the open
documentary lab because of the microsite
moments of innovation
which is a fantastic precedent for the
kind of media historical openness that
constitutes this field that i'm trying
to explore
one thing you'll notice is that many of
the practitioners i mentioned have never
and may never self-identify as a
documentarian
just because i'm trying to read their
artistic gestures through critical
description it doesn't mean that i
always agree with the artist's
intentions
if you like that's one of the critical
differences to this kind of description
it begins with a disentanglement of
intention and effect
and as a critic you always start with
your experience of a works effects
and then decide where and how far you
want to take your inferential projection
at the moment the examples i've gathered
include scrapbooks book scanning devices
billboard posters a computer game a
tumblr based poetry press shadow
libraries and a performance work
organized around a single rubber stamp
so it's a real melting pot of mostly
cross art form practices
what i'm going to show you today are
just six examples that center in on the
mobilization of textual documents across
contexts
but all of these are done explicitly in
or via the frame of aesthetics that's
aesthetics broadly put be that as
literature art or whatever mongol
combination of registers
so these examples are practices where
the artwork as both process and outcome
is based on the republishing of already
public documents
and by republishing what i mean is to
make public again for a more than
private audience
which is an act that need not involve
printing
so i'm going to show you those six
examples in three pairs effectively in
three subsets
and i'm going to use the sequence of
those subsets as a very quick way to
abridge a few of the key moves in the
argument of the book
as it's taking shape
now that argument leans on the work of a
core group of theorists
especially
lisa geithelman on the document
you see parrika on media archaeology
rachel malik on the horizons of the
publishable
and a number of people on documentary
aesthetics from allison james to carlos
guerra to forensic architecture
now this hodgepodge of
will shake out in the writing
but right now you'll probably hear
echoes of them all in a drip feed as i
describe the examples
the three subsets of examples i'm going
to share each coheres around a format as
well as an artistic intention
and i've done that in part to help keep
some of the jumps between subsets clear
for today
the book chapters actually mix the
formats of their examples but that
doesn't really matter right now
for our purposes today the first subset
of examples begins with print publishing
practices that are in some sense extra
literary
the second subset jumps to experimental
video predominantly artist moving image
work
and the third subset jumps to
cross-platform digital first archives
syllabi and software
now i've picked examples for today that
either have a us resonance or i hope
somehow kind of usefully strange
so in the first subset we'll start with
an odd precedent in documentary editing
from the british left going back to
humphrey jennings in the
1930s and then we'll look laterally to
something more open and enmeshed which
is middleton harrison
uh milton harrison tony morrison's the
black book
in the second subset i'll show you two
artists moving image projects
the first of performative video work by
anyaka igwe
the second a simple epic by steve
mcqueen based entirely on scanning
in the third subset i'll show you a
project about counter archiving by paul
sue ellis
and lastly an activist co-learning tool
and shareware project called the pirate
care syllabus
now building up through the subsets
there is some sense of a kind of
deformation of documentary norms
so it's in that sixth phase of
platformatics and shareware tools that i
think there might be a break from
anything we could usefully still call
the documentary
a break caused by creative misuses of
documents as documents
for now that's just a hypothesis rather
than a claim
but i figured that it's worth you
knowing that trajectory up front
okay
so to the first subset now the influence
of the filmic idea of montage on
documentary literature is well known and
well discussed
and of course we can go back to a
pre-film era and talk about documentary
literatures from 19th century france to
the 18th century pamphlet cultures and
we can keep going backwards looking more
and more widely
my first example adapted montage very
literally
it was in a sense a lifelong project by
someone who might be most familiar as a
co-founder of the mass observation
organization
humphrey jennings was an english
documentary filmmaker and a prolific
editor collagist writer and organizer
the page scan on the left
was jennings first substantial attempt
at using the filmic method of montage as
a literary one
it's an addition of a little art
magazine called the london bulletin from
july 1938
and in it jennings's contribution is a
series of buttressed quotations
a stream of text excerpts from other
writers
they're effectively long quotations
cited at the bottom of each entry
and type set as plain text
the quotations are organized
chronologically by publication date
and his header note explains his purpose
these excerpts are meant to document the
experiences of humans during the arrival
of the machine age
it's a purely quotational practice
and running as a linear body text page
after page each quotation works like a
segment of footage spliced into a film
in fact jennings called each quotation
an image
now the method of sampling used here
culminated in a book called pandemonium
it was put together by jennings's
long-term collaborator charles madge
after jennings died
based on the extensive preparatory
papers and research notes that jennings
left
the book is made up of 372 entries each
of which is just a quotation
you can see a sample spread on the right
here
all of these entries are organized
chronologically and that chronology is
divided into four sections or chapters
there are image plates that intervene
with the text rather than just
illustrate it
but in its form the book is a fairly
straight print publication
what's less straightforward are three
reading aids embedded in the paratext
two of which invite the reader to
recompose different sequences from the
content
one is a traditional subject name index
and the other is a list of so-called
theme sequences
which is something i'll explain in a
minute
although it was published in 1985 in
many ways pandemonium is the oldest
example i'm looking at because jennings
died in 1950
it's really serving me as a deductive
example
one that shows pink print cultural norms
pushed to their limit in a mass-market
publication
and one that's primarily structured by
other documents
but invokes them without showing them
this is a method of montaging in the
fashion of documentary literature which
is one form in the long tradition of
quotational writing that comes from
scriptoria
what this generates is a documentary
epic
it's built from quotations treated as
images
spliced into invented correspondences
through the active montage
all of which starts with a quotation
from milton's paradise lost
and ends with a quotation from william
morris's dream of john ball
so this is an overtly poetic overtly
romantic critique of dehumanization
during the industrial revolution
one that sets up a romantic distinction
between the science of history with a
capital h
and the power of multiple lib
perspectives to testify to human
experience in the name of art
as a different way of marking histories
plural
formerly interesting is that it's
paratex invites three readings
the first straight through following
page order and therefore chronology as
you might watch a film
the second extractively via names and
subjects in the index
and third thematically through 15 listed
theme sequences
now these theme sequences are listed
just after the final entry and each list
proposes a different topical remix of
the content
these theme sequences have titles like
industrial man and earth and creation
and each one cites between 14 and 40
entries from the main body listed by
their number and title
now these might be small gestures
and pandemonium doesn't show documents
per se
but it does show how the formal
structure of the book as itself a
document can be prismatic
it can internally refract its content
and structure
it can redirect but also pluralize
connections between its content
through the montaging of quotations and
the prismatic formal use of alternative
reading devices
the book as a document unsettles the
history it documents
it's polyvocal and plurilinear
it offers lots of lines through the
content
but they are lines or predetermined
sequences and that's a key difference
between quotational practices like
pandemonium and my next example which
reproduces its source documents
now of course in community archiving
practices in familial record keeping in
private processes of scrap booking even
commonplace books and communal ledgers
the montaging of documents within a book
as container has a long history
but in documentary print publishing
practices you have to re-share the
content through the form of the printed
edition
which is something that takes on a
social life one that you can't control
and in that sense involves a different
kind of risk
it becomes generative of a more than
private audience it generates a public
so published works have a different kind
of social life from those kept private
now pandemonium does take that risk but
i think this next example doubles down
on it in several ways
it makes and declares a shift from the
single editorship to collaboration
it makes and declares a shift from
quotation to reproduction
it makes and declares a shift from rigid
linear structures to a multi-directional
tethering of content to content
relations
and it makes and declares a rejection of
reader reference tools that would ease
interpretation
it's a shift from the polyvocal
plurilinear model offered by jennings
to a constellation of hybrid content
it's a move from linear evidence
equalized in plain text
to an experience of being disoriented
and enmeshed in the various things that
these documents can be offered as
evidence of
now i'm guessing this example is more
familiar so i'm just going to describe
it very quickly
what you can see are the front cover and
a page sample from the first edition of
the black book
its construction is attributed to
middleton harris and three co-editors
because much of the material comes from
an archive of african-american culture
developed by an organization that harris
founded in 1964.
what's come to be known since the black
books first publication in 1974
is that the books commissioning editor
tony morrison was also a driving force
in composing it and in generating a
wider context of reception for the
material
the book's dimensions are those of a
photo book or catalog and it runs to 198
pages
there's a simple style sheet for the
layout of those pages
they have a three column structure and a
rigid page header featuring the title as
a logo form alongside the page numeral
but the main body moves without
explanation between running text in
those columns and reproduce documents
photographs advertisements newspaper
articles sheet musics
all kinds of things photographically
reproduced
so the run of the plain text content
operates much more like a newspaper than
a modern book
meaning the entries can cut into each
other
this isn't a simple montage of images
arranged back to back
this is something more complicated more
speculative which hybridizes its content
and nowhere in the book is there a
reference index for the sources of the
material reproduced or for those bits of
newly authored plain text
both pandemonium and the black book
compose together
multi-perspectival traces of the past
very crudely put the difference between
them at the level of documentary
aesthetics is that pandemonium offers
its evidence in plurilinear ways and via
quotation and reading aids
whereas the black book enmeshes the
reader in its evidence by refusing to
explain its framing methods and evoking
the power of indexical reproduction
for me
this kind of documentary book publishing
is a really important precedent for what
i'm calling document practices
for a start they're not cleanly literary
nor simply authored
plus they're self-reflexively composed
through an awareness of their media form
the book as itself a document or even a
meta document
now another trope of talking about
documentary is to point out that
document comes from the latin dosser as
in to teach or to show
and in her book paper knowledge lisa
geithelman does a great job of warning
against the temptation to neatly
conclude that a document's job is to
document as in to teach its teaching
her warning is important because
documents can't simply teach their own
lessons
to explain this problem guyton proposes
the concept of the no-show function as
in
k-n-o-w show as in no from knowledge
now this formulation of the no show
function was a real spark for my own
project
i think it's a brilliant theory for
understanding the document as what she
calls an epistemic object
very crudely put guidelines point is
that documents exist as such to record
something to be evidence that something
is known
the knowledge only becomes operative if
it's shown as in shared
so the function of the document is to
know and show
but of course showing is always a social
act so the context of that showing then
affects what its knowledge stands as
evidence for
documents by definition are self-evident
of something but what that something
means is contextually dependent
and can also therefore change with a
recontextualization
documents have to be mobilized and
that's why their social life matters
now the first subset of examples started
to exercise this no show quality of
documents
but my second subset really intensifies
it
because
through moving image they make literal
or literally figure the process of
mobilizing documents as evidence for
something
both of these coming examples feature
embedded documents but they do it in
different ways and two different effects
my first of these examples is a six
minute hd video work by anyaka igwe
it was triggered by iguay spending time
in the archive of the british colonial
film unit which was an ethnographic arm
of the british empire
iguay's video is called her name in my
mouth and it was released in 2017.
in it she uses 16 millimeter footage
from the british colonial film archive
shot in pre-independence nigeria between
1933 and 55.
it's the kind of footage from the empire
that would have been farmed out as
propaganda to new sources and the like
now in iguay's film that footage is
sampled often looped or played back
repeatedly
and it's intercut with sequences of
iguod performing to camera in a photo
studio type setting
her performance is a response to some of
the movements and dress she sees in the
footage
crucially for me
the work also features a second level of
archival response
we watch iguay identifying opening then
taking us through an official report
document
this is the official account of an event
in nigeria in november 1929
known as the women's war or the abba
women's protest
in fact it's the report from the inquest
that followed the very brutal response
to that uprising
the camera is positioned rostrum style
during this situation
per the conventions of archival
recording
and iguay's hands and fingers guide the
viewer as reader through the document
like a living
manicure once we're guided into the body
of the document the frame jumps into
close-ups
tv documentary style
and we get a succession of very partial
clips that change too quickly and crop
too tightly for us to really read the
text with any degree of context
this is a brilliant complicated and
powerful work that you can watch in full
at screen definition on
vimeo the sound design is just as
important as the other aspects
the sound's built from a combination of
recorded singing ambient music and the
diegetic noise of the actions eagwe
makes to camera like rubbing dutch wax
cloth or opening the folder containing
the report
the work is all about embodied
experience
about iguay thinking feeling her way
through a critical proximity to the
material
and it asks for a kind of multi-sensory
reading
i'm just going to play you a
three-minute excerpt to illustrate what
i mean
there's sound on this so hopefully
you'll hear it all
m
hey
[Music]
more
my
so from the
photo printed on a t-shirt
[Music]
[Music]
from the photo printed on her t-shirt to
the 16 millimeter archive footage to the
inquest report
what we have are documents reproduced in
multiple ways
these reproductions as traces are then
forked across media
so they can be mobilized in embodied
ways that literally rob them against
each other
what iguay seems to be doing
is to take a sort of a set of
documentary film tropes normally used to
narrate the meaning of documents
and adapts them to instead complicate
the meanings of those documents
and to put herself right at the center
of that complication
now what we see in the next example also
misuses tropes of documentary film but
turns them away from the body away from
the self-portrait and towards the kind
of portraiture that is rendered by
surveillance
formally this work has a kind of
conceptual clarity that is registered
mechanically through a riff on the
cinematic convention of the end credit
it's an ongoing project by steve mcqueen
called end credits and it was begun in
2012.
the visual content of the work is just a
single continuous scanning shot that
lasts for six hours
what rolls through the frame are high
resolution flatbed scans of sheets of
paper
buttress then to end at jennings's
quotations
so the movement is digitally simulated
but it feels like watching a kind of
blown up microfiche reel or a really
strange credit sequence at the end of a
movie
the sheets take about 15 seconds to roll
through the frame and a 16 9 projection
ratio you see about half a page at any
one time
that means each line of standard body
text is on screen for about seven
seconds which is to say it's up there
for long enough to be read
this video mobilizes the textual
document so as to make it unavoidably
legible
monumentalizing it through a register of
cinema
and turning its experiential endlessness
into a kind of allegory for the topic of
its content
what i'm showing you now is an install
shot of this work on show at the whitney
in new york
at the end of this vast empty room
stands a huge cinema scale projection
wall
behind which through the full wall
windows you can see the outside world
the very social fabric under critique
this next photo is from the same showing
now it's a shame i can't play with a
little clip because what you can't see
in the photos is the second dimension of
the work it's sound
the sound plays asynchronously alongside
the projection
so both are always playing but their
timings are independent of each other
the sound remains the unfinished aspect
of this project
it's currently over 40 hours long and it
features individual voice over artists
or pairs of voice over artists reading
out the documents scrolling on the
screen
in the style of something like a
prepared testimony or scripted public
speech
the content of these documents the
history allegorized is every page in
sequence from the fbi surveillance files
on an african-american man called paul
roberson senior who was a popular singer
but also a socialist and an intellectual
these documents were privately stored as
reference material within the fbi
organization
but were laterally published in response
to a freedom of information request
you can still download them all as pdfs
from the fbi's digital vault online
now these documents have lots of layers
the pro forma structure underneath which
is mostly printed
the data entry by the fbi agent which is
hand written or typed
the marginalia added in for correction
by archivists
the rubber stamps and date markings that
register the document's history of
receipt and storage
and then the redactions throughout which
black out
content all of those layers are
flattened into a single image by the
scanning process
which carries forward the visual noise
of the original copying process and of
its digital remediation
throughout the footage has been turned
into a hard contrast black and white
file
and this removes the yellow tone of the
paper as if to clarify the allegory by
intensifying the impression of a binary
conflict a black and white matter of
fact
both iguay and mcqueen's work complicate
the portrayals of real people in history
by complicating the status of the
documentary evidence used to underwrite
those portrayals
both are formally challenging
yet they position their audiences at
different distances
iguay exposes herself
playing with and to the problematic
power of the documentary image to incite
empathy
in its sheer unwatchable relentless
scale
mcqueen's work keeps us at a
spectatorial distance
in that troubling way that
post-conceptual allegory can
but both works also trade on the doubled
legibility of textual documents
reproduced as images
that those documents become both graphic
and graphemic
that their linguistic content is
mediated in a form that encodes the
context of their social history
in both works the no show function of
the document is the foreground issue
undercutting documentary portraiture
in both cases the bind between knowing
and showing is foregrounded through
time-based gestures that are formal and
performative and remediated as image
sequences
sequences made dissonant by the sound
design
and by the presence or non-presence of
other visual content
with all of that said the two videos use
textual documents in an obviously
different way
one embeds them among other content
including documentary content
the other just is its documents and
nothing else in image or sound
now given the hypothesis of my project
this difference is really significant
because it dredges up the classic
problem of exactly how documents are
mobilized in documentary aesthetics
we can call this the problem of
facticity
leaning back onto geithelman but also
outwards to aisle weissman and his
theorization of forensics
or alison james and her work on the
documentary imagination
documents are facts in a slightly
brutish sense
they're materially specific things that
record something else
something that they're evidence of
but beyond that quality of being
self-evident figuring out why they exist
or what that something else means
requires interpretation
documents are not self-sufficient beyond
their own thinness
they are themselves a mediatory form or
an intermediary one between the moment
of their production and the context of
interpretation
so any truth that a document might
evidence depends upon what it's made to
represent within a bigger symbolic
schema and the representational
structure it's mobilized in
be that in the name of art or the law or
whatever else
in mcqueen's work that bigger symbolic
schema is art and the representational
structure for contextualization and
interpretation is primarily determined
by the other documents from the same fbi
file
of course there are lots of implicit
cues in the cinematic form of the work
and it's exhibitionary staging
but end credits doesn't embed or couch
its documents in a kind of narrative
framing that is typical of mainstream
documentary
and nor does it intercut those documents
with other content in the way that's
typical of experimental documentary
instead it's a kind of wholesale
reproduction
it uses the medium of digital video to
network a folder of documents
making them legible again in public
in a way that re-contextualizes whatever
they might make might be evidence for
precisely because they are now graphic
and graphemic in an aesthetic sense
so we watch them mound up as a pile of
indexed evidence
waiting to be put to use
now you could be annoyed that i just
described the simple act of sequential
scanning as a gesture that networks a
folder of documents
and you might be right
in the case of end credits that might be
a bit of a stretch because the network
it creates is a closed circuit of
representation it settles its own bigger
picture if you like
but this stretch to an actual networking
of documents is the one that i think my
final subset of examples manages to make
and it's this stretch that i'm
hypothesizing might constitute a break
from documentary norms
so just to recap what i said at the
start i've started to notice an
intensification of practices that make
aesthetic use of textual documents as
documents
in ways that i'm not sure we can
usefully call documentary
these last two examples i'm going to
show you are both instances of counter
practice in the sense that they work
with and against lots of coordinates
for a start they both work through art
but primarily not as art let alone for
art's sake in any neo-modernist sense
both have primarily fluid digital forms
and work as usable tools
both make public or publish a structure
a simple platform architecture for
finding published documents cataloging
them and for republishing documents
they network readers and documents
enabling unlimited communities of
readership
readers who can also become librarians
and publishers
in doing so they also enable documents
to be endlessly recontextualized through
the network
legally or illegally
my first example from subset 3 looks a
lot like the documentary publishing in
subset 1 returning us to paper and the
codex
but it has none of the same literary
intention we saw in jennings or
middleton's work
this is a project by paul suellis called
steve harvey and matt
it was launched in 2018
and its premise is pretty simple
to recover and republish a body of web
assets about climate change that were
originally published by the
environmental protection agency online
between 1997 and 2017.
these assets started to be purged in
april 2017 under governmental order
through a freedom of information request
suella's got access to the emails and
spreadsheets that detail this purge as
staff are instructed to take down
references to climate change and replace
them with a stock note about president
trump's executive order on energy
independence
now there are three media channels to
sue ellis's work
the first is a 735
print-on-demand book containing all of
those emails and spreadsheets
organized by correspondence chain
you can see a page sample on screen
the main body text is obviously a pdf
export from an email archive
and because these documents are born
digital they're reproduced as original
copies
simple exports
from web to print
such that they appear indexacle
that movement from web to print is
actually a kind of back and forth in
this project
and the design for the book's cover
spread does a good job of signaling that
back and forth
as you can see now on screen laid flat
as it's designed
the cover spread looks like a computer
screen
it shows multi-layered content and
desktop icons that signpost the two
other channels of the work which are a
downloadable zip folder and a live
stream broadcast
there are two online anchors for this
project the one you can see on the left
which is a github page that embeds the
project in an ecosystem for community
development
and the one you can see on the right
which is a bespoke web page at
epa.archive.org
this second page is the live stream
its broadcast re-shares the 1964
epa.gov links that were purged
it shares them one at a time in a random
order every few seconds
now this project takes its title from
the opening line of the first email in
the disclose correspondence
hence its weird direct address
but steve harvey and matt is also a
proof of concept for the digital system
behind it a system suelis calls
archive.work
all three channels of steve harvey and
matt offer open editions
the printed part is print on demand so
the content can be updated and there's
no stock limit
likewise the file and link content can
be revised at any time
this cross-platform architecture creates
what suellas calls a counter publishing
system
that could accommodate any similar
archive of politically threatened public
information
or what suellas calls urgent archives
now my final example is an open-ended
collaborative project by valeria
graziano marcel mars and thomas vlad
medec
again at the back end it's a sims it's a
system for publishing and sharing
and the front end i'm showing you is the
first application of that system
this first proof of concept is called
pirate care syllabus and it was launched
with a workshop in 2019
from that workshop the online syllabus
you can see on screen was generated
you can find it at syllabus.pirate.care
this project tries to map connect and
support certain forms of activism
mostly self-organized on-the-ground
groupings who innovate strategies of
collective care to redress social
injustices
more specifically these are practices of
care that are forced to work in the grey
areas of the law or outside of it all
together hence the reference to piracy
now the syllabus creates an index for
these groups
each group is registered as a topic
and then within their topic area online
each group can co-develop a set of
learning resources to share their
expertise
organized as a set of sessions
all of the teaching resources and their
further reference material published by
a group in their topic area is stored
via synchronized library on the shadow
service memory of the world
this ensures that all of the republished
material is robustly stored and stably
accessible
so pirate care syllabus is the first
application of this triadic structure
that can be infinitely cloned and via
which new content can be forked
each syllabus has topics and within each
topic there are teaching sessions
you don't need to be able to code to use
the system and the pirate care team
maintain the structure
there could be an infinite number of
syllabi
now what runs the back end system is a
software called sandpoints developed by
mars medic who also co-founded memory of
the world
sandpoints this development software is
a public tool for radical republishing
and librarianship
it's also one of the limit case examples
that my research has stretched towards
pirate care was initially commissioned
as a cultural project
it was the basis for the exhibition
learning from disobedience in rieka in
2020 which you can see on screen
it's also been adapted into contemporary
art exhibitions at venues including the
constella vienna
wherein the conditions of exhibition are
treated like a public forum
so the pirate care team use these
exhibitions as a chance to extend the
discursive ambition of the project
they host new discussions and workshops
moving back and forth between the online
and the offline all in an effort to
expand the legibility of the documents
they're accruing
so that those documents and their
librarians the activist groups
can show what they know
now all three of the people behind
pirate care still work in the arts in
different ways
one relevant example would be the diy
book scanners by mars and medic which
you can see now on screen in an
exhibition from 2014.
what pirate care seems to do is work
through the context of art as a space in
which speculative making and speculative
publics can be realized as if the form
of art is little more than a
transitional object
this phrase transition object is one
borrowed from donald winnicott by carlos
guerra to describe the political
inadequacy of contemporary art
now noticing this tendency for radical
publishing practices to make things as
art or using the context of art as a
zone of permission that publishing
practices can transition through
was the basis of my hunch behind this
new book project
in the first subset of examples i showed
you we saw some of the legacies of
montage and documentary print publishing
linear in jennings's case
hybrid and constellatory in the black
book
both are poly perspectival but both
examples were composed with a poetics of
locked form
in the second subset we saw a
transmedial movement with documents and
documents reproduced indexically
in igwe's work these are embedded in a
narrative frame
in mcqueen's work they form a monumental
allegory
i think the intentions form and effects
of this final subset are significantly
different
here the unit of aesthetic intention is
not one edit of some source documents as
we saw in subset one
nor is the intention to splice excerpts
of documents with other content
as we saw in iguay's work
nor is the intention to create one
particular configuration of the
documents as we got in the queen's work
in suelici's
archive.work and even more so in the
case of pirate care and its back end
software standpoints
the unit of intention is the network
the networking of people to documents
and storage systems and sharing systems
that network generates access through
its open form
the effect of the intention is to
propagate access to documents cross
contextually and to enable readers to
become publishers and librarians of
document collections
now if we remember that the realism
registered by all documentary art forms
is the reality of the documentarians
attempt to access the world
then we could say that these extreme
document practices enable anyone to
become a documentarian
that's fine
but that leaves me wondering as a critic
how we should talk about the work of
these people who make the back end
systems
that bit isn't yet clear
and i'll leave it there
all right thank you i'll stop sharing
thanks so much nick this is great
and
um
while i wait for
uh
the clapping hands to turn into
questioning hands
in the zoom participant
um
uh
list here i'll uh offer a question
myself
um so i'm fascinated with the teaching
role of the document and also with its
monolithic nature that steve mcqueen i
think most um
expressively and conceptually uh put
forth
um in that project that you showed
documentation of at the at the whitney
uh i mean in in that case it's a
monolith in the 2001 style not just a
monolith in the unitary
style
um
do you think there's a tension between i
mean one thing we can say is that um
texts of various sorts are
to some extent all documents
it seems
um
and yet they're also all
parts of a
discourse and the discourse perspective
gives us an idea of response and
fluidity
we
hopefully will have a discourse now that
we're in the q a section the
the document perspective gives us
the
lecture style teaching it's
you know it's an and the um
uh and it foregrounds the fixity
and the the materiality and um
uh the um unity and the encapsulation
of a text
um
what do you see about this
duality of discourse and document how
does how does your perspective on these
texts as documents um inform your
perspective on them as discourses or
parts of discourses
it's a really great question i mean i
think there's two sides of it one's
about legibility
and the other is about actually their
connectedness rather than a kind of
binary separation so the connectedness
would for me come through those kinds of
philosophical traditions that were
inflected by like uh you know the
sociology of literature and stuff like
that so this is people like michelle
desatu the idea of the scriptural
economy right where there would be
everyday practices of writing
registrations of inscription and they
would circulate in all manner of forms
forming a kind of ecology
of the scriptural and and i'm basically
quite invested in that i think is my
confession
the second side about legibility is a
really interesting one and that's what i
think makes these aesthetically really
interesting that they offer up a doubled
legibility they call up their media form
all that visual noise that tells us it's
a document
so in the mcqueen case that's the
redactions the pro forma underneath that
structures the page etc they call up all
of that aesthetic information to tell us
it's something materially specific
but they also
have the chance to operate at kind of
lexical level right such that i think
you know
the idea that i'm starting to find
useful to link these two things is the
idea of the diagrammatic actually this
doubled legibility so
that diagrammatic idea could come from
two places on the one hand in terms of
semantics it could come from joanna
drucker the idea that like formats are
significant
um and in the other way it would come
from like media archaeology the kind of
berlin school ernst that sort of thing
the idea that
[Music]
machines generate processes that
encourage
connection
right
so i i think that's the way
for me the the text is document thing is
about legibility and this question of
legibility is a doubled one it's graphic
and graphemic it's image and semantic
content and that's the unique aesthetic
quality and i'm tr i think i'm starting
to understand it through the idea of the
diagrammatic but it's you know i'm still
working on it
all right one or more of uh srishti jj
abby emily
and
um
and ali have a question
so let's find out what that is
hello hello you can see us all here
um
the question is from me i'm abby um
thank you so much for the talk
i have kind of two questions and the
first one is shorter and it concerns
your use of the word misuse
in terms of misusing
documents as they're intended to within
documentary practice but it seems to me
that
documentary as a form has been slippery
as the way that you've termed it since
the beginning of its history so i'm
curious to hear you talk about your
choice to use this word misuse um like
what is it
in opposition to
and if it is um you know a form of
drawing attention to
a lot of these kind of more grassroots
and distributed ways of using documents
as in all of your subsets then um
you know what is the implication of the
word misuse because also all of these
subset examples that you've um indicated
have been published have been circulated
um okay and then my second question
um which is sort of related to that um
concerns
how you're thinking about the social and
historical conditions in which all of
these documents are being produced and
how you are reproducing them within your
own work and the reason why i ask this
is because it even seems to me in subset
one when we have the humphrey jennings
quotation book versus the tony morrison
edited black book as examples
you know the reason for the linearity of
the humphrey jennings book
stems from the fact that it is um i
don't know a book of quotations on one
person whereas i
you didn't explain what the black book
is exactly um other than you know what
it comprises of in terms of its format
but i assume from the title of black
book that it's supposed to be you know
some sort of survey perhaps or um
reconstitution of um
you know
first of all i guess my question is what
is the black book but you know there are
reasons i'm extrapolating for why it
would be um collaborative and
multi-vocal
because it's trying to represent i
assume
blackness in america as opposed to the
words of one person so i'm curious about
how you're thinking about that when
you're writing about all these different
works
thank you that was very long
there were two great questions and and i
love a question coming from a communal
dinner table which is a very nice way of
doing it i'll take the first one first
and then the second one if that's all
right so so to the first the first one's
really about mobilization right like
documents have to be mobilized to mean
anything and so the thing is documents
are always made for a purpose we don't
just kind of make documents for no
reason there's always a sort of reason
that they're there to evidence something
and whatever that
initial purpose is establish that
document establishes that documents norm
if you like right that's the should be
purpose
so a misuse
would be the mobilization of that
document the re-mobilization of that
document for some other purpose
it's literally like a counter move if
you like so that's what i mean by misuse
okay
and by mobilization what i'm talking
about here is the fact that um
okay
each document is evidence of something
but figuring out what that evidence
means requires contextualization right
and that's the mobilization part like it
has to be put to something something has
to be done with it has to be brought
into a context of interpretation
okay so that that's i hope that makes
sense but that will be my answer to your
first question
the second one is a really great one i
can't do it justice in this moment
because it's an extraordinary book if
you ever get a chance to to handle it in
the library or anything like that it's
really worth doing you can still get
cheap copies actually the first edition
online but it's um
it was a collectively edited project
that assembles
some
newly authored content but mostly
reorganizes elements from an archive
with no
um explained order
that would be the simplest way of
putting it
and in refusing to explain its order
it establishes a very poetic kind of
counter critique
of normal ideas about history
about white time and about all kinds of
things um
so the black book is this extraordinary
thing that looks somewhere between
a scrapbook
and
uh
almost like a fansy at length
um the material ranges from like i say
of all kinds of stuff
a lot of which is uh
very
is like
that confronts one as reader
and precisely because you you get this
book you get this very short
introduction from bill cosby weirdly
and then you get this extraordinary back
jacket text on the first edition and
that back jacket text is actually by
tony morrison but she's not noted as
such there
um but that's all you get there's no
kind of reader aid at all so you're sort
of invited into this kind of
constellation of content
and
and your reading is not secured
right and and the kind of vulnerability
that asks for is i think really
extraordinary it's really an enmeshment
and enmeshment in that constellation and
i think that's a that's something that's
very different from what's achieved by
the kind of back-to-back montaging of
clearly cited content
where you get all that control mechanism
that makes it a kind of safe experience
so like i said i can only give you a if
i had it to hand my kids are upstairs
asleep otherwise i've got stuff and get
the book to show you but
but um
yeah that it's an extraordinary book and
do seek out a copy if you get a chance
really worth looking at
thank you for joining us at this
equinoctal
time
uh
i mean i have another question
while we wait to see if there's a yellow
virtual hand that that arises i'm just
curious so we still have um
physical bookstores and oddly enough we
still even have like a
dvd and blu-ray sections in those
bookstores
here in the united states also we have
barnes and noble for instance and uh
you've shown us these great and amazing
examples of
book based documentary
um but if i go into the um
dvd and blu-ray section of these
bookstores i'll find a subsection there
called
documentary
and so my question is why don't we have
such a section there's
true crime poetry
um
non-fiction fiction
why don't we have a documentary section
in the um
in the book part of the bookstore
yeah it's a it's a really good question
and
it's in part about classification
standards as they come to modern book
selling i'm sure from library cultures
and stuff like that it's also about the
historic divisions within
let's say literature you know we've got
kind of
fiction drama poetry and the other stuff
so we don't have we also don't have
non-poetry yeah
we've got non-fiction but not non-poetry
right
but but i think
a base it's about this slipperiness of
documentary i mean i mean what is it
because
if it could be said to be a kind of some
sort of autonomous
uh
what would be saying sort of genre then
and then i guess you know you could make
a subsection in a bookstore
um
[Music]
but it seems like it's a very marginal
practice unlike documentary filmmaking
which
you know we we recognize what that is we
have festivals for that there's
you know you can go to the new york art
books fair and
there will be there will be documentary
books there for instance
but
uh you have to look around
for these for whatever you know queer
archive work by par paul sue ellis or
or
you know the projects
of the sort that that you mention or
even even the black book which is
you know
like
like very well selling and popular
project but it's um
it stands out as something very unusual
right yeah yeah yeah totally and and
i i would describe
those kinds of print documentary works
as extra literary in the sense that they
clearly have like a literary reflexive
consciousness
but
they're not obeying norms of like
genre or anything else they're stepping
outside of the literary space and doing
something else in this pocket of
documentary practice so this idea the
extra literary would be where i would
situate them if you have to but of
course it is in itself a kind of
negative category like a non-category um
but that's but that's how i think about
this i think there's definitely an
upsurge in gatherings of these kinds of
documentary literatures through
print-on-demand cultures
right where right where you might move
quite quickly from the kinds of
softwares in which you could compile
this kind of thing to a pdf that could
be rendered printed and sold sure and
many of these are art projects they're
not they're not
contained within
literature
um
so
but i think i think what's interesting
about the extra literary category is it
is it it can encompass the kind of you
know the folk
it can encompass all kinds of things
that that could bleed into it from the
fan
to the you know so
yes there there are certainly art
projects and those are the ones i'm
looking to because i'm interested in
this question as a critic but but but i
would say that one of the things that's
most exciting is about this kind of
non-space of the extra literary is that
it's porous
at right and it's not governed
you know so so like sure yeah i work
with you know counterpath press which
uh at times styles itself as a publisher
of literature and non-literature
um
yeah they were they've been involved
with that those really great sort of uh
translations of heim rebecca and stuff
right so you know there's a really good
example in documentary poetics which of
course is a thing a sub-genre thing
documentary poetry
yes
and uh appropriating your idea from on
the subcontract actually they also
published a book a day
where they got mechanical turk workers
to all just respond to one of donald
trump's tweets
um but they did this on on a daily basis
so that they actually like every there's
one tweet per day
just creating a book full of
um
you know responses by people
who are enlisted and paid to do this
so well let me i mean we can go i i can
i can talk with nick
um you know
all night but uh he needs to go to sleep
let me ask if there's a final question
because we don't i haven't seen any of
those yellow hands
so
i think we might we might release
our guests
to
dormitic respite
um in that case but uh let's first of
all let's first of all thank him very
much
uh this was
this is very stimulating and we we have
some evidence of our of ourselves
through this portal
um
thanks
uh so this is great i think it's going
to give us things to discourse about
in coming days and weeks
and
um uh we very much hope that you'll be
able to um manifest in your material
person at mit before way too long but we
do appreciate this conversation and your
presentation
uh thanks again
i'm really grateful thanks guys and
thanks for having me